Hello, and welcome to This Week
in Android Development
for July 22, 2013, live from
our brand new Android
Broadcast Studio.
My name is Reto Meier.
Last week, the Google Play Games
team put on a show to
help your web games take
advantage of Google Play Games
services and the Android Design
in Action team cast a
critical eye over one of our
GDG App Clinic Oslo apps as
well as providing some insight
into how to create a
consistent design
for your apps.
Our Australian colleagues held
their first Fireside Chat on
making apps beautiful on Android
Developers Backstage,
and Ankur followed up with
the next of his DevBytes
explaining how to make your
apps beautiful on tablets.
Not to be outdone, Chet was back
for an exciting episode
of his Animation DevBytes.
More on that later.
The Android Developer Survey
is still open,
but closes this week.
This is your chance to tell us
what works and what doesn't,
or just that we ask far
too many questions.
Next week, Ankur is back for
more beautiful App DevBytes,
and Chet, well, you'll just
have to wait and see what
Chet's got in store.
Last Friday's cricketing
humiliation delayed our
scheduled episode of the App
Clinic when a drinking game
involving the fall of Australian
wickets went
horribly wrong.
It's been resceduled for this
week, but Australian viewers
beware, it contains screenshots
taken during the
second test.
This episode is a little
different from our usual App
Clinic format with a deep dive
into the architectural
decisions and design that go
into creating an efficient
low-latency sports score
tracking app.
So tune in and find out how to
make your app's architecture
as beautiful as its
visual design.
As always, you can go
to developers.googl
e.com/live/android to see what
we've got planned for ADL this
coming week.
That's all for this week
in Android Development
for July 22, 2013.
And remember that the dust from
a distant sun will shower
over everyone.